if you could have brought a caddy today
we'll wrestle you're all playing with me
later
you bring the eel I pick these I'd you
bring Nick Foles
I was thinking maybe Bella check Bill
Belichick caddy for me just to see how
my you know tiger still came out they'd
like took three swings and they're ready
to go so I'm thinking about three
thousand I have to I have to pick those
few moments that were far between where
I were was able to beat tiger and 2012
AT&T was one of those and I had this old
lade with a white-hot XG insert from
Odyssey that I putted phenomenal with
shot 64 to his 75 won the tournament and
that that putter has been known
throughout the Gulf circles is the tiger
Slayer and so I brought that out for
this particular event you're throwing me
off here you're you're taking me away
from my focus Amanda but we've already
done the math yeah we figured it out
we've we've got to formula we just got
it I go to go execute that I thought he
would go good good just to like get the
match going get it friendly no ever feel
this like everybody's got an annoying
friend who's really really smart and you
ask him some simple and he gives you
like the brain surgery answer
maybe fairway Oh Martin southern Chuck
you got any swing tips for me I'm
struggling hey brother
this is I'm not the I'm not that guy you
need tips from I've seen Phil do some
odd things before but having TWP marked
that ball is you have one ah the avenue
i got some silver ones you have any of
the gold ones you don't want to work so
on the chipper jones think it just let
you know you can I'm just saying that's
for myself you can be great in one sport
and not great in another sport
I just want America to know that well
right on cue my partner's gonna make
this right here these aren't the Falcons
you're playing against Tigers a pretty
good closer same colors though it's the
Eagles that I cringe bro not the Falcons
I'm sorry Chuck but my partner's call me
in for a read he's a lot more important
than you are step on that you step on
that Michigan they haven't been good
since you left
you know I sucked in hard yeah did you
feel when I suck the energy toward me
Tiger there's one way that that ball
miss I think we willed it out I really
did I think we did that was the deep
inhale Wow well if our will game is
strong we might have it there yeah we
might have a chance check out this box
non-football bro dominate
[Applause]
shut your mouth shut out here I haven't
hit a good shot in eight holes so I'd
like to speak for a little bit every TV
that was shot
no wasting any time for the half
unforced error that's a game
Charles can you believe that they you
know Tom and field kind of have matching
outfits
they wanted you know if I'd want to wear
black and red like tiger I'm like I'm
not wearing black and red that's Georgia
Bulldog colors I mean I just can't do
that I mean it you want me to get sick
on the first hole I'll do it but you
know I'm not gonna let Kirby Smart get a
picture of me and black and red for
their social media accounts so the other
thing I think about is what would
Charles not do
that's good three four - so protector -
it is so partner it's going to Eli would
have made that one your ball
they'd be up yeah might be there they
don't make Manning not wasting any time
for the half unforced error that's a
game of checking it is a gentleman's
game is it you know one with a birdie
but it's a win like it's not dumb change
the fact we're only one down now